we've been spending quite a few lectures
so far discussing some or at least
regularity lemma it's applications and
various variants of the regularity lemma
so I want to spend one more lecture
before moving on to a different topic to
tell you about other extensions and
other perspectives on similarities
regularity lemma so hopefully you know
you're all or become experts of the
regularity lemma especially with
practice especially the next homework
problem set where there will be plenty
of problems for you to practice using
the regularity level so one of the
things that I'd like to discuss today is
a hyper graph extension of the triangle
removal Emma so as we saw the triangle
removal Emma was one of the important
application of similarities graph
regularity lemma okay so that works
inside graphs but now let's go to hyper
graphs in particular even in the case of
three uniform hyper graphs where okay so
let's set some terminology so on our
uniform hyper graph
or simply abbreviated as our graph
consists of a vertex set an edge set
where the edge set consists of our
tuples so the edges are our element
subsets of the vertex set so R equals
the two corresponds to the graph case
and you can talk about sub graphs
density various counts all analogously
to how we did it for graphs and you can
imagine what the hyper graph tree
removal lemma might look like so let me
write down the statement for all our
graph H and epsilon bigger than 0 there
exists a delta such that ok so last time
there was some complaints about
sentences going on too long so let me
try to cut sentences into smaller parts
so if G is an end vertex our graph with
small number of copies of H so H S sub
graphs then G can be made
H free so so far everything's still the
same as in the graph case but now the in
the graph case the number of edges is
quadratic most quadratic here it's a
most end to the arc
so I want to make this graph this are
graph H free by removing less than
epsilon n to the our edges from all
right so that's the statement of the
hyper graph removal lemma so it's an
extension of the graph removal among any
questions about the statement so before
discussing the proof let me show you why
you might care about this statement and
we used the triangle removal amma to
deduce Roth's theorem remember there was
a graph theoretic set up where start
with a 3 AP free subset we set up a
graph and then that graph has some nice
properties that allows us to use a
corollary of the triangle removal mo
namely the corollary that says that if
you have a graph where every edge sits
on exactly one triangle then it has a
sub quadratic number of edges so we can
do a similar type of reduction showing
that the hyper graph removal 'mom
implies some Redis theorem so that's
what we'll do so that's the deuce
Sammarinese theorem
from the hypergraph removal mmm
so recall somewhere this theorem says
that for every fixed positive integer
okay if it's a subset of 1 to N that
escapee free has no K term arithmetic
progressions then the size of a is sub
linear instead of illustrating how to do
this proof or general K I'm just going
to do it for the case of K equals to 4
and you can look at the proof and it
will be clear how to generalize so we'll
just illustrate the proof for for a
piece now before even showing you what
this proof looks like you might wonder
do we really need the hyper graph
removal lemma could it be that with the
graph removal amount and the more clever
choice of a graph you could proof some
rarities theorem using just that so we
set up some graph previously where
triangles correspond to three P's maybe
you can set up some other graph where
some other kinds of structure correspond
to for a piece and it turns out the
answer is emphatically no right so it is
actually it's something so there's a
very good reason for this
that for these are things which we might
go into more when we discuss additive
combinatorics but for a piece it's a
pattern that's sometimes called
complexity to where it's three APs
there's a pattern which is called
complexity one I won't go into the
precise definitions of what this means
but the message is that you cannot prove
the for ap theorem with just graph
machinery that you really have to use
something stronger that there's there's
a very real sense in which just the
graph removal Emma is
at least some relish theorem
similarities regularity lemma is not
enough and so we really do have to go to
hypergraphs and this extra layer of
complexity like in this word sense of
the complexity introduces also
additional difficulties in there so that
theorem is significantly harder than the
graft removal em up so I won't even show
you anything that's close to a complete
proof but I will illustrate some of the
ideas and highlight some of the
difficulties today but deducing
somewhere this theorem from the hyper
graph removal lemma is actually not so
bad so I will show you how to do that
right now
so from the hyper graph removal em up
even just for three uniform hyper graph
even for tetrahedron so instead of
triangles you can tetrahedron we can
have the following corollary analogous
to all we have for triangles so if G is
a free graph such that every edge is
contained then G has a cubic number of
edges so completely analogous to the one
that we have for triangles and the proof
is identical you read the proof and
everything works exactly the same way
once you have to remove all Emma
tetrahedron I mean the complete graph on
four vertices a complete free graph on
four vertices four vertices and you look
at all possible triples of vertices all
right so now let's prove similarities
term at least the for AP case the
general case is completely analogous of
course you have to go to higher order
instead of three graphs you have to look
at our graphs
all right so just as in the proof of
Roth's theorem we're gonna set up some
particular three graph where let's look
at a certain modulus so M being 6 and
plus 1 I mean the exact number is not so
important here I really just want that
this number is bigger than 3n and its
co-prime to 6 see some divisibility is
by 2 & 3 that will be useful so let's
build a four-part I'd 3 graph G where
the for vertex parts X Y Z W they all
have okay so M vertices each and I'll
show you what the edges are so four
vertices little X in big X and so on ok
so here are the rules for putting in the
edges so I'll just tell you exactly what
they are so I put in an edge X Y Z if I
know me F the following expression 3x
plus 2y
okay so 3x plus 2y plus Z lies in a I
put in the edge X Y W if I know me F 2 X
plus y minus W missing a
okay so X Z W if and only if X minus Z
minus 2w missing name and finally Y Z W
if and only if minus y minus 2z minus 3w
so these are the rules for putting in
edges of this hyper graph okay so you
have this hyper graph and you might
wonder you know why did I choose this
expression so if it's not clear yeah
well soon be very clear why we do this
just as in the proof of Ross theorem
using triangle removal amount let's
examine the tetrahedra in this free
graph so what are the tetrahedra notice
that X Y Z W is a tetrahedron all three
triples are present if and only if all
four of these expressions lie in a
or just like an improver roster these
four expressions form a for AP and the
common difference is minus X minus y
minus Z minus W okay so they were chosen
to satisfy this property but furthermore
notice that you know I can't just put
any expressions and I put these
expressions in with a very nice property
that the eighth linear form does not use
the eighth variable so each expression
really corresponds to an edge in this
three graph all right but we started
with a set a that is for a p3 it follows
that you don't have this kind of
configurations unless the common
difference is zero so the only
tetrahedra correspond to these trivial
for a piece and just as in the proof
ross theorem that we saw from triangle
removal lemma the conclusion is that
every edge lies in exactly one
tetrahedron and therefore by the
corollary the number of edges is equal
to little Olaf M cubed but on the other
hand how many edges are there so for
each of the four conditions here so for
each of these four parts the number of
edges is or you get to choose x and y
whatever you want and the last variable
has a choices so this implies that the
size of a is little o of M and M Masson
the same warders n and that proves the
theorem any questions so far
yeah great questions where do we use the
condition that M is co-prime to 6 does
anyone know the answer great so to solve
for the last variable we have to maybe
divide by 2 or 3 and to do that you need
to have co-prime mallove you with 6 so
I'm hiding a bit of details here
okay it's a quick question so if you
work all the details of this statement
here every edge slicing exactly 1
tetrahedron and also counting the number
of edges but actually more especially
the first sentence you need to actually
do it just a tiny bit of work any more
questions all right so this deduction is
the same deduction that's the one that
we did for triangles but you have to
come up with a slightly different set of
linear forms and usually if you're given
a specific pattern you know you can play
by hand and try to come up with this set
of linear forms you can think about also
how to do this generally and more
generally this hypergraph removal em'ly
using this type of ideas it allows you
to reduce multi-dimensional similarity
theorem so if you give me some pattern
then a subset of the integer lattice in
a fixed dimension avoiding that pattern
must have density going to 0 so we
stated this in the very first lecture
and I won't smell all the details but
you can follow this kind of framework
and gave you that theorem and I will
post a problem where you're asked to do
this for a specific pattern namely that
of a domain
x-squared an axis aligned square if you
have that pattern in z2 we're thinking
about how would you run this argument
for that pattern in z2 yes okay okay
it's question how close can be so you're
asking what is the rate this little all
and gifts let me address the case oh
hold on to this question I will address
it once I discuss what is known about
hyper graph removal EMA and that's a
great question and there's a lot of
mystery surrounding what happens there
okay questions any others great so let's
discuss this hyper graph removal a mom
and as I had warned you already at the
beginning of lecture this one is very
difficult so I mentioned in the very
first lecture that so the development of
similarities regularity lemma was a
stroke of ingenuity but this one here
and but but no we started the proof when
we did a proof of similarities traffic
alert in among in one lecture and once
you understand it it's not so bad but
it's you know you do the energy
increment conceptually it so it's not so
bad but that one there is actually
incredibly difficult it's incredibly
difficult both conceptually and
technically but I want to at least
illustrate some of the ideas and give
you some sense of the difficulty like
why is this difficult so as we imagine
we have graph regularity and to proof
hyper graph removal one would develop
some kind of a hyper graph regularity
and the basic idea in hypergraph
regularity or just regularity in general
is that I give you some arbitrary graph
or hyper graph and you want to find some
kind of partitioning some kind of
regularization into some bounded number
of pieces some bound amount of data so
that that's a good approximation for the
actual graph just like in a graph
regularity case so let's try to do this
like so what does this partition even
look like so here's an attempt and of
course I call it a temp because
eventually it will not work but it's a
very natural first thing to try and all
right maybe it's I shouldn't call it
naive cos it's actually not I mean it's
it's not it's not a bad idea to begin
with
okay so let's let's see so suppose you
were given a three graph G I'm going to
just to help you remember
what's the uniformity of each graph I
will denote in parentheses in the
superscript I should just help you
remember that this is a free graph so in
geometry they also do this with many
faults so if you put an N on top it's an
N manifold okay but this 3 is for 3
graph suppose we partition the vertex
set of the street graph similar to proof
of some radius regularity lemma so think
about how the proof of similarity
circular element goes right so you have
this partition but in the proof you know
there is this iterative refinement and
each step you say well I have this
notion of regularity if it doesn't
satisfied with regularity I can keep
cutting things up further so what's the
notion of regularity that might get you
some kind of vertex partition you can
anyone think of a notion of a regularity
for three uniform hypergraphs
okay so let me try to rephrase what
you're saying so if we have so some so
notion of regularity let's say I have
three vertex sets v1 v2 v3 and I want
that the density between these three
they do not differ from if I restrict
these vertex sets to subsets that are
not too small does this make sense so
here this D is the fraction of triples
that are edges of the hyper graph so
this is the natural extension natural
generalization of the notion of
regularity that we saw earlier for
graphs and indeed it's a very natural
notion hence it is a nice notion and
actually if you use this notion if you
use more or less precisely what I've
written you can run through the entire
proof of similarities graph regularity
lemma and produce a regularity theorem
that tells you given an arbitrary three
uniform hyper graph you can decompose
the vertex set in such a way that most
triples of vertex sets have this
property right so the same proof
as somewhere this regularity lemma
implies okay so I all I won't write down
the entire statement but you get the
idea so for every epsilon there exist M
such that we can partition into the
vertex set into at most M parts even
equitable if you like so that a most an
epsilon fraction of triples or parts are
not epsilon regular in the sense that I
just said it so literally it's the same
proof right so you really look at the
proof and you get that okay so so far
everything seems pretty good pretty easy
so why did I say initially that actually
hypergraph regularity is incredibly
difficult so what it's not good about
this one also remember in our
application of the regularity method
there were three steps partition cling
and count
okay so partition do partition cling or
do some kind of cleaning but counting
that's a big thing so and that's
something that it wasn't so hard we had
to do a little bit of work but it wasn't
so hard you can ask is there a counting
lemma associated to this regularity
lemma and the answer is emphatically no
and I want to convince you that for this
notion of regularity there is no
counting lemma yes it is true so is this
version true so this statement is true
with this definition and you can prove
it by literally rerunning the entire
proof of similarities graph regularity
lemma all right so the regularity
statement I've written down is true but
it is not useful for example it cannot
be used to prove the tetrahedron remove
all I'm up because if you try to run the
same regularity proof of the removal
lemma you run into the issue that you do
not have a counting number okay so why
is it that you do not have a counting
lemma so let me show you an example and
keep in mind that the notions of
regularity they are supposed to model
the idea of pseudo randomness which is
the topic we'll explore further length
in the next chapter but the idea of
pseudo randomness is that I want some
graph which is not random but in some
aspects look random so this is an
important concept in mathematics and
computer science and it's a very
important idea but of course you can
generate a pseudo-random object by just
taking a random object and should
hopefully satisfy some properties of
pseudo randomness so let's see what this
notion of regularity how it works
even for random hyper graphs what's a
random hyper graph okay so there are
different ways to generate a random
hyper graph one way is to have a bunch
of triples or appearing uniformly at
random independently at random so I have
bunch of possible triples I can make us
I just each one I flip a coin but
there's a different way and let me show
you a different way to generate a random
free graph
let me give you two parameters P and Q
they are constants between 0 & 1 so
let's build first a graph so a random to
graph child call g2 so this is just the
erdos-renyi random graph GMP the usual
one where you flip a coin for each edge
so that each edge appears with
probability P independently and now I
make the actual throughout that one g3
by including every triple so every
triangle of GQ as an edge
so here an edge mean it's a triple some
edges three vertices in the hyper graph
with probability Q so it's a two-step
process I first generate a random graph
and then look at the triangles on top of
that graph and each triangle I include
as a triple with the probability Q if
you like you can be even one so I do a
random graph and my hyper graph is a set
of triangles okay and let's compare this
construction to the more naive version
of a random hyper graph where we look at
this hyper graph where I put in each
triple
appearing independently with probability
P cube Q so these are two different
constructions of random hypergraphs
and you can check that they have
basically the same edge density alright
so how many edges appear in the first
one well the density of triangles in g2
is P cubed and each of those triangles
appear as an edge further with
probability Q so they have similar edge
densities and furthermore you can check
that this condition here is true for
both graphs right so both graphs satisfy
this notion of epsilon regularity as
just defined with high probability okay
great so if you had a counting lemma it
should give you some prediction as to
the number of tetrahedra that come
directly from the densities in
particular they should be the same for
these two constructions but are they the
same
so the density of tetrahedra in the
first case okay actually let's do the
second case first in B okay so what's
the density of tetrahedra so if I have
four vertices so each of those three
edges appear uniformly at random
independently so the density of
tetrahedra is just the edge density
raised to the power four what about the
first one okay so in the first one to
get a tetrahedra the underlying graph
needs to have a k4 so P raise to 6 and
then on top of that I want 4 Q's
okay so P raise to 6 Q raise to 4 and
when P is different these numbers are
different so this is an example showing
why there is no counting lemma because
you have two different graphs that have
the same type of regularity and
densities but have vastly different
densities of tetrahedra any questions
about this example shows you at least
why this naive attempt does not work
this if you follow our regularity recipe
all right
but your any case it's dope it's good
for something so it's you don't have a
counting Lima for tetrahedra but
actually you can still salvage something
so it turns out there is a counting
lemma if your graph H if this our graph
H is linear okay so linear means every
pair of edges intersecting at most one
vertex so for example if you look at so
that's hyper hyper graph where each line
is an edge of triples okay so that's a
linear hyper graph because each pair
intersecting at most one vertex
tetrahedron is not linear to phases of a
tetrahedron can intersect in two
vertices okay so you can try to prove
that this is true and actually the proof
is basically the same as the counting
lemma that we saw for grass
but of course how many edges can a
linear hypergraph have you mean given a
bounded number of vertices that's I'll
leave you to think about it more
questions but for the Guate we really
care about naming tetrahedra which
relates to some radius theorem this
method does not work alright so what
should we do what should we do instead
let's come up with a different notion of
regularity and that's someone inspired
by that example up there where we need
to look at not just triple densities
between three vertex sets but also what
happens to triples that sit on top of a
graph so we should come up with some
notion of an edge density on top of two
graphs
so given a B and C being edge sets a
complete graph so these are graphs the a
B and C you should think of them as
graphs and a free graph G we can define
this quantity D of ABC so there's always
a hidden Jeep which I'll usually omit to
be the fraction of triples
XYZ where the XYZ or such that they sit
on top of ABC so Y Z lie in a XZ lie in
b XY line c okay so the fraction of such
triples that are actually triples of G
so in the case when ABC are the same
it's asking what fraction of triangles
are edges of G but you are allowed to
use three different sets so think of ABC
s no red green blue I'm asking for
fractions of red green blue triangles
that are actually triples of the
hydrograph alright so now we can try to
come up with some notion of regularity
[Applause]
and as you might expect at this point we
it's not sufficient to partition the
vertex set instead what go further well
partition the edge set of the complete
graph and so will partition the set of
pairs of vertices
let's partition edge set of the complete
graph as a union of graphs such that we
would like a similar type of regularity
condition but for those types of
densities such that for most I J and K
such that we have lots of triangles on
top of these three graphs in the
partition so for most i j k such that
this is such the case they in this
partition so this triple is regular in
the sense that for all sub graph
with not too few copies so not too few
triangles on top of these ace one has
that the density the triple density
among the g's is similar to the triple
density on top of the ace okay so I'm
doing some kind of partition where G one
it's like that G two that and G 3 yeah
and what I'm saying is that if you take
subsets of G 1 G 2 G 3 so that there are
still lots of triangles right and that's
analogous to this condition of a is not
being too small then counting the number
of triples to the fraction of those
triangles that are edges of G that
fraction is roughly the same when you
pass down to sub-graphs okay don't worry
about the specific details and I'm not
going to try to give you the specific
details but think about in analogy to
instead of partitioning the vertex set
we are partitioning the edge set of a
complete graph but actually hyper graph
regularity involves one more step namely
that we need to further regularize
these G's using so via partitioning the
vertex F similar to what happens in
similarities graph regularity lemma but
actually more similar to the strong
regularity lemma that we discussed last
time so the data of hypergraph
regularity is not simply a partition of
the vertex set but its twofold one is a
partition of the edge set of the
complete graph so a partition of the
vertex pairs into pseudo random graphs
so in two graphs so that the hyper graph
G sets pseudo randomly on top and on
furthermore there's also a partition of
the vertex set of G so that the graphs
in part one are extremely pseudo random
with respect to this partition in this
idea of extremely random we saw in last
lecture you have some the sequence of
epsilonc that depend on how many parts
you have in the first step of the
regularity okay any questions
your question is what happens to triples
of g's that do not have lots of
triangles so they are similar to in in
grass you have these small sets of
vertices so you have to you have to deal
with them somehow but I'm again leaving
out all these technical details and in
fact I'm writing down a very sketchy
version of hypergraph regularity you
could write down a more precise version
you can find it in new de jure in fact
can find more than one version of the
statement of hypergraph regularity in
literature and they're not all obviously
equivalent it actually takes a lot of
work even to show that different
versions of the statement are equivalent
to each other and it's still somewhat
mysterious to you know what is the right
you know the most natural formulation of
hypergraph regularity that's something
that i think we still do not yet have a
satisfactory answer there was a question
earlier about bounds okay so what kind
of bounds do you get for hypergraph
regularity so let me address that issue
now
so what kind of pounds do you get well
for summer this graph regularity lemma
the pound is at our function because we
had to iterate the exponential which
comes out of the partitioning and in
hypergraph regularity because of this
extremely pseudo-random so you are doing
some kind of partitioning the first
stage and then you are iterating that on
top for the second stage similar to how
we did strong regularity in the last
lecture so the bounds for hypergraph
regularity is also iterated power which
we saw last time and this is no one the
wowser okay so it's even worse than in
the then graph regularity and just like
in the case of graph irregularity this
wowser type bound is necessary at least
for most statements any of these useful
statements of hyper graphs regularity
what about the applications so
applications to multidimensional cemani
theorem okay so first of all to
summarize a theorem well you can prove
somewhere any turn this way and you
would get inverse wowser type bounds
which is it's not so great but there are
better proofs so there are more
efficient proofs quantitatively so for
similarities theorem the best result for
general K is due to cowers which tells
you that a must be at most n over
something that's log log and raised to
power some constant C depending on K for
K equals to 3 and 4 you can do somewhat
better before
okay this is the best bounce so far but
for multi dimensions for
multi-dimensional patterns it turns out
that well historically the first proof
of the multi dimensional similarity term
was done using organic theory which has
even worse balance compared to this
approach in that the organic theoretic
proof gives no bounce because it has to
use compactness arguments so they
actually gave no quantity of bounce and
one of the motivations for this
hypergraph regularity method the removal
lemma is to produce quantitative proof
of multi-dimensional summary term so in
general still the best bounds come from
this removal mo so hypergraph removal
lemma although in special cases and
really not that many special cases but
really just the case of a corner as we
saw earlier you have somewhat better
bounds or so for corner you have bounds
which have density like poly log log but
even for a geometric square we do not
know any four-year analytic methods we
do not know other methods and this is
basically the best bound coming out of
hypergraph regularity and there are
serious obstructions to trying to use
Fourier methods to do other patterns
such as geometric square any questions
yes
okay so what are the bound for higher
degree uniformity do you so this is wow
there's four three uniform and four for
uniform you iterate wowzer
so you go up in a command hierarchy you
iterate wowzer you get a four uniform
hyper graph regularity lemma and so okay
let's take a short break
what
so the second topic I want to discuss
today is a different approach to proving
similarly scraf regularity lemma and
this is a good segue into our next topic
which the next lecture which is about
pseudo random graphs in particular the
idea of the spectrum again values in
particular play a central role so I want
to consider a spectral approach giving
an alternative way to prove the
similarity regularity lemma
and if you're already sick of the
regularity lemma at this point so this
will be the last topic regularity lemma
for now although it will come up again
later in this course when we discuss
graph limits this is the last thing I
want to say and just like the discussion
about hyper graph regularity it will be
somewhat sketchy so for so this idea I
mean has appeared in literature in the
past but it was popularized like many
good things in life by Terry house block
so it's a good place to look up a
discussion of what I'm about to say okay
so we saw the proof of regularity lemma
via this iterated partitioning and
keeping track of our progress through
the use of an energy but here's a
different perspective namely if we start
with a graph G I can look at the
adjacency matrix a sub G so this is the
N by n matrix where n is the number of
vertices whose IJ entry is 0 if I is not
adjacent to J + 1 if I is adjacent to J
so this is a pretty standard thing to
look at the Associated graph to this
matrix so this graph here and so on it's
a real symmetric matrix and that's
always pretty nice symmetric matrices
have lots of great properties that will
be convenient to use in fact if you like
myself if you're too used to working
with symmetric matrices you'll forget
that some of these properties actually
do not apply in general to non symmetric
matrices it is symmetric so so we're
happy so for symmetric matrices we have
a set of real eigenvalues
so we have real eigenvalues and
eigenvectors and for now let me
enumerate the eigenvalues by lambda 1
through lambda n so multiplicity
included and I sort them according to
the size of their absolute value so the
spectral theorem tells us a
decomposition so here again we're using
that a is real symmetric so tells us
that this matrix a can be written as the
sum coming from the eigenvalues and
eigenvectors where the uise uisce are
the eigenvectors but i can choose them
so that they form an orthogonal basis
orthonormal basis so there are all unit
vectors when I say the spectrum I mean
this data also specifically this set of
eigen values all right so let's go
through some basic properties of the
spectrum so first how big can the
lambdas be so I claim that so first of
all the sum of the absolute sum of the
squares of these lambdas yes
let me not even call this a lemma so
it's observation so the sum of the
squares is this one so this is the trace
of a squared which is also the sum of
the squares of the entries so here I'm
always using that a is real symmetric
sum of squares of entries okay
and I mean in the case when you have a
being adjacency matrix this is simply
twice the number of edges which is at
most and squared always a good thing to
remember okay so as a result the right
eigen value cannot be bigger than what
so you have heigen values right so
they're sorted in decreasing order so
the eigen now it cannot be too large
particular it cannot be larger than and
over good eye because otherwise the sum
of the first I I can W squared would
exceed n squared
so these things they do decay okay so
second second observation is that if you
have some epsilon and an arbitrary
function so this is known as a growth
function just that's just a name to
worry about it so we'll call f so it's
function from the positive integers the
positive integers and for convenience
I'm going to assume that f of J is
always at least J for every J there
exists some C which depends only on your
epsilon and the score function so this
growth function plays the same role as
the sequence of decaying epsilon in the
strong regularity lemma so there exist
some constant bound such that for every
graph G and a G as above so associated
with the lambdas and use there exists
a J less than C such that if I sum up
the eigen values squared for eigen
values I index between J and C F J this
sum is fairly small it's at most epsilon
and squared I'll let you ponder that for
a second so choose your favorite growth
function it can be as quickly growing as
you can can be exponential tower or
whatever and it's saying that I can look
up to a bounded point so that this
stretch of spectrum squared is at most
epsilon N squared question
the statement hopefully will become
clear once I show you the proof all
right okay so here's how you would prove
it so you first let j1 equal to one and
I obtained the subsequent J's by
applying F 2 J alright so I claim that
one cannot have this inequality violated
for too many of GPS GIS so one cannot
have the sum going between J k and j k
plus 1 for all K from 1 to 1 over
Epsilon
you cannot have this because if you had
this then you sum up all of these
inequalities you would get that their
total sum would exceed N squared which
would violate the inequality about the
sum of the squares of their spectrum and
so therefore so thus to the claimed
inequality so this is true star holds
for some J equal to ji where J K where K
is less than 1 over epsilon and this J
in particular is less than or it's
whatever it is it's bounded right so
it's less than F applied to itself
almost 1 over epsilon times okay so this
should look somewhat familiar and you
see you know so I asked you to think
about it wrong how this proof of
spectral the spectral proof of
similarities graph regularity lemma
compared to the proof that we saw
earlier and you should see where the
analogous step is here this is the
density it's the energy increment step
all right okay so what's the regularity
decomposition so I give you this graph I
give you this adjacency matrix and I
want to be able to find a partition but
there's a different way to view a
partition so let me this is I think a
important idea which again is
popularized by Mike Terry tell now
instead of looking at things as a
regularity partition we can view these
ideas as regularity decompositions
namely I so pick J as in dilemma and I
now write my adjacency matrix a sub G as
a sum of three matrices which we'll call
a structured plus a small plus a
pseudo-random where a structured equals
to the sum for basically that sum this
sum here so this spectral decomposition
but up to but only for the first J minus
1 eigen values so those of you coming
from I've taken classes in something
like statistics my recognizes as a
principal component analysis so this has
many names it's a very powerful idea you
look at the top spectral data and that
should describe you most of the
information that you care about about a
graph or a matrix in general the small
piece is the Samba only for J between so
for I between J and 8th of J and the
pseudo random piece is for I at least
half of J
okay so we decompose this adjacency
matrix into these three pieces and the
question now is what does this have to
do with similarities graph regularity
lemma so what do the individual
components correspond to in the version
of the regularity lemma that you've seen
and are now familiar with so here is
what's going on so I want to show you
that this structured piece roughly
corresponds to the partition so this is
the bounded partition and the small
piece roughly corresponds to the small
fraction of irregular pairs and the
pseudo random piece roughly corresponds
to the idea of pseudo randomness between
pairs all right first to understand like
what the spectral data have anything to
do with partitions let me remind you a
basic fact about the how the spectrum
how the eigenvalues of a real symmetric
matrix relate to other properties of
this matrix and namely this notion of a
spectral radius or sometimes called
spectral norm so so far I'm only going
to discuss real symmetric matrices so
many of the things I'll say are not true
for if you're not in a real symmetric
case so the spectral radius spectral
norm is the of a is the largest
I can value of a in absolute value and
this quantity it turns out to be equal
to the operator norm which is the norm
of this a as a linear operator namely it
has the Max or super it turns out to be
a max of a V over length of a V divided
by length V so if you hit it with a unit
vector how far can you go so it's also
equal to this bilinear form if you hit
it from left and right by unit vectors
how big can you get so for real
symmetric matrices these quantities are
equal to each other and that will be an
essential fact for relating the spectral
data with combinatorial quantities all
right so if you give me this
decomposition how can I produce for you
a partition basically you can look at a
structure which has it stayed in its
data a bounded number of eigenvectors
and by rounding let's we can basically
round these guys so when you round the
individual values by rounding the
coordinate values so let's pretend that
they
take only a bandit so let's say a small
number of values so just to simplify
things in your mind pretend for a second
well of course this is far from the
truth
pretend for a second that these guys are
0 comma 1 valued of course that's not
going to be the case but you know so
your common 1 know plus minus 1 if you
like ok so this is definitely not true
but for the purpose of exposition let's
pretend this is the case and you can
more or less achieve it by rounding the
individual values to to their nearby
closest multiple of something then the
level sets of these top eigenvectors
they partition the vertex set into a
bounded number of parts
right so if you for example in the
simplified version where you only have
plus minus 1 values for these
eigenvectors then you have a most two to
the J parts you may get some more
because some epsilon but okay so for the
purpose of illustration is let's not
worry about that and this is basically
the regularity partition I want to show
that this set here has very nice
properties that they basically behave
like the regularity partition we've
gotten previously so what I would like
to show is that the other two parts they
do not contribute very much in a sense
of our regularity partition so for
example if you look at the pseudo-random
keys if I hit it left and right with
indicator vectors of vertex sets how big
can this number again so this number
here is at most
well the norm of U plus times the norm
of this W which is just okay so let me
write down okay so the norm of indicator
of you know I'm indicator W multiplied
by the operator norm of pseudo-random
part of a but these few guys here so
there are most root n each so so this
number here is at most and but we know
from our hypothesis the pseudo-random
part of a that the spectral norm is no
more than this quantity over here and by
choosing F appropriately large I can
make sure that this number is extremely
small
F to be large compared to the number of
parts in the partition so so this
quantity is small and this is basically
the notion of epsilon regularity that
you saw in the usual version with a
diversion of similarities regularity
lemma I presented in the first version
in the very first lecture that we
discussed regularity this quantity here
it's something which measures the
difference between so for now if you for
now for a second ignore the middle piece
if you ignore the small piece then this
is precisely the difference between the
actual densities between U and W and the
predicted density between U and W ok
question is why is your square root here
there should not be a square root good
then becomes square root of ya so
there's no square root buddy the length
of this vector is the square root of the
size of U which is a most end
okay questions do we need this how smart
we won this f of j2p so I want this
quantity to be quite a bit smaller than
let's say okay so basically I want to be
less than F of N squared but F of and
over the number of parts squared because
this quantity is I say the the sizes of
each part not precisely much less than
so this quantity here is the size of
each part and I want you think about the
case when u and W they lie inside each
part in which case I want the difference
to be much less than epsilon times the
size of the part squared questions it's
the J different based on the graph yes
and that's also the case for summer
least regularity lemma similar these
regularity lemma you don't know when you
stop but you know that you stop before a
certain point okay and finally what's
happening with a small part of a so in a
small the sum of the squares of the
entries okay so this also has a
convenient name it's called the hilbert
smith norm so the sum of the squares of
the entries it's we basically saw this
calculation earlier is the sum of the
squares of the eigen values in which
case you know we've truncated all the
other eigenvalue so the only eigenvalues
left are between J and index between J
and f of J and we chose J so that this
number is small
so a small ass in a bunch of noise but
adversarial noise if you will into your
graph but only a very small amount the
most Epsilon amount so it might destroy
this it might destroy the epsilon
regularity for let's say around epsilon
fraction pairs but that's all it could
do so all but an epsilon fraction of
your pairs will still be epsilon regular
and that is the consequence of some
release graph regularity lemma that we
saw earlier yep okay so question test
large F have to be specialty F should be
chosen if you want to achieve similar
this graph regularity lemma you should
find this F so that basically this
inequality is true so f should be quite
a bit larger than the number of parts
but if you choose even bigger values of
F you can achieve more regularity and
this is akin to what happened with
strong regularity so there's this idea
if you iterate one version regularity
you can get a stronger version the
regularity and there's some iteration
happening over there so if you choose
your F to be a much bigger function of J
you can achieve a much stronger notion
the regularity which is similar and
perhaps even equivalent to strong
regularity that we discussed last time
so you get to choose what F you want to
put in here
of questions how do you make it
equitable you can okay so so let me let
me not discuss that so in this case you
can now so I mean do very similar things
to what we've done before but to massage
the partitions it's not yeah so it's not
entirely clear from this formulation but
the message here is that there's just
equivalence between operator norm on one
hand and combinatorial discrepancy on
the other hand and we'll explore this
notion further in the next several
lectures